This is how you should be warping to the
Roundtable Hold. Done. It's that easy! Now
be honest, how many of you are still
dragging your cursor there manually? Instead,
you should press triangle or Y to open the list
of grace checkpoints, then you press square or x
to confirm a warp straight there. It took me..way
too long to discover that this was a thing.
Elden Ring is full of little quality of life
things like this that are never explained,
so I'm going to start this video by
quickfiring five more at you.
For example, if you walk through a beacon of
light that you've placed..then that beacon
will disappear. This is an excellent way to mark
that actually you've reached your destination,
without having to pull up your map.
Next, if an enemy explodes in a burst of
blue light, that means they're going
to drop an item. Don't miss it.
When you pick up an item, take note of this icon.
This tells you which category of your inventory
that item just went into. This will make it way
easier to figure out what you just picked up.
Another great way to find what you just picked up
is to press L3 on the inventory menu. This will
let you sort in order of acquisition, and look
over all the items that you recently looted.
By default though, your inventory is sorted into
vertical categories, demarcated by horizontal
lines. For example, the bolstering materials
tab organises your crimson flask materials,
your smithing stones and your somber smithing
stones into their own sections.
Now with those quality of life tips out of
the way...let's get into the big stuff.
First, how would you like to have a
buff that gives you 5% extra runes?
To get this, all you have to
do is type in 7 letters.
In the last video, I announced "Secret Seekers",
our community group password. Enter "SEEKERS" in
all caps as your first group password in your
multiplayer tab, and you'll be able to identify
phantoms, bloodstains, messages and summon signs
from others in the group. Our goal is to find
secrets in the game, and share them with others.
Since then, I can't go 5 minutes without finding
evidence of you guys hurling yourself off cliffs
in search of secrets. You make me so proud.
Since then, we also discovered that every time
someone in the group defeats a shardbearer,
or becomes Elden Lord, everyone else in the group
receives a 5% buff to their rune acquisition..and
considering there are thousands of you in this
group..this buff activates like..constantly. So
join us, and enjoy your free runes.
Also..I put the SECRET SEEKERS logo onto a shirt.
So, if you want to rep our unofficial covenant
- check it out with the link below.
Another way to get free runes is by duplicating
your remembrances. Goddrick's, for example,
gives 20,000 - and subsequent bosses give
even more than that. Every major boss drops
a remembrance, though the proper way to use
these is to trade them in for boss items at
Enia, the Finger Reader at Roundtable Hold.
Because each remembrance can be traded for
multiple items, it's possible to duplicate them at
the walking mausoleums found throughout the game.
Here's what some of our testing revealed:
First, there are six mausoleums in total. One
in Limgrave ... Three in Liurnia ... one
in Mountaintops of the Giants ... and one
in the Consecrated Snowfield. The method of
bringing down a mausoleum differs in some cases,
but it's generally related to removing
the white curse marks from its body.
It's worth finding your way up to each
of these, because you can only duplicate
one remembrance per mausoleum. After duplicating,
that mausoleum becomes pretty obsolete.
interestingly, you don't actually
need the remembrance in your inventory
to duplicate it - you just have to have
defeated the boss you got it from.
Also, note that you cannot duplicate
remembrances that you have already claimed
all the items from.
And make sure you use your
duplications before heading to NG+, because your
remaining duplications won't carry over.
In addition to getting a remembrance, defeating
a shardbearer will also grant you a Great
Rune. Once acquired, you have to go to its
corresponding Divine Tower and "activate" it.
After doing this you can "equip" a great rune at a
site of lost grace, with your equipped great rune
appearing in the top left of your screen.
These Great Runes bestow powerful effects upon
your character - though equipping the rune doesn't
actually apply its effects - instead, to do that,
you'll need to consume a "Rune Arc". These
powerful consumables are a reward for invading,
doing co-op, exploring the world..and killing
rats. Yeah. Rats. Just like they drop humanity
in the Souls games, they also drop Rune Arcs
sometimes. The lore here is that even the
most valuable items make their way down to
the bottom rung of the food chain..to these
creatures that consume the bodies of all.
Every great rune does something different.
Godrick's, for example, increases
every one of your attributes by 5,
essentially granting you 40 extra levels.
Characters that use a wide variety of spells and
scalings will benefit most from this, and some of
the later great runes are even more powerful.
Without a Great Rune equipped, a rune arc
will increase your max HP by about 10%. All of
these effects persist through warping, which is
great - and will last until death, or re-equipping
a Great Rune. Essentially it's Elden
Ring's equivalent of being embered,
or having your hollowing reversed.
So remember: make use of Rune Arcs. Don't just let
them sit wasted in your inventory. Equip them to
your pouch, and pop one whenever you're on a very
difficult boss. It might turn out that a Rune Arc
could tip you just over the edge, to victory.
Rennala's Great Rune is a bit of an outlier.
Unlike the others, it can't be equipped,
and it doesn't need to be activated by a Rune Arc.
Rather, it can be used to respec your character.
Talk to Rennala at Raya Lucaria, and
you'll be able to bring your character
back to their starting stats, with all your
previous levels ready for reinvestment.
This process requires that you defeat
Rennala of course, but also that you have a
Larval Tear. These are very rare, but to tell you
about the location of at least one - there's a
royal soldier located here in Limgrave..that
drops one. Be careful though..kill him,
and he might just be reborn anew.
Elden Ring is a long game. So..consider
switching things up! I mean..they keep giving
me spells that my melee character can't use! So
you know what..maybe shooting
meteorites does sound like fun.
Another way to fix your character might be
via pardoning, which - let's be honest - is
a mechanic that exists for when you put down your
controller and accidentally press the R2 button
in front of an NPC. Alternatively, it's also
useful when giant dogs attack NPCs through walls
and they get upset at you, instead.
That said..most important NPCs can't be
attacked in this game...so what is
this for, really? In testing this,
I realised..it must be for the merchants.
Because logically - you should be killing
every merchant you see. Once you kill them,
you can just buy all of their items in one place,
at the Twin Maiden husks at Roundtable hold.
That said..it's very traumatising to
kill a merchant. Just listen to him.
So, if you regret this
decision - ask for forgiveness,
and the merchant will become friendly again.
If you really do have some angst to let out,
don't take it out on NPCs that don't
really exist - take it out on other
human beings, instead, like a normal person.
Your item for infinite invasions is the Bloody
Finger, which can be acquired by progressing
Varre's questline to the Rose Church.
Speak to him before defeating Goddrick, then
again afterwards at Roundtable Hold, then at
the Rose Church in Liurnia, located here.
Here he'll give you five festering bloody
fingers for invading other players - use
three of them to progress his questline,
where he will next require you to soak the Lord
of Blood's favour in the blood of a maiden.
One exists in the Church of Inhbition located
here, in Liurnia. Interact with the maiden, and
return to Varre to receive the Bloody Finger.
Alternatively, you can pick up the Recusant's
Finger at the Volcano Manor - and this
one has a different story affiliation
to the invaders of the Bloody Finger.
But if you'd rather engage in duels with
other players, then you'll need the Duelist's
Furled Finger, which can be found on a corpse
at the doors of the Stormhill Colosseum.
The Small Red Effigy can also be found here,
which serves the same purpose, except it sends
a competitive summon sign to the Summoning Pool,
instead. Summoning pools are accessible at
these effigies, found throughout the world.
And if PvP is something you'd like to
avoid - well, pick up the white cipher
ring from the Twin Maiden Husks at the
Roundtable hold. With this buff active,
you'll automatically request help from another
player when your world is invaded. If you want
to BE the player that helps invaded players, then
you can use the Blue Cipher Ring, instead.
Also in the Roundtable Hold is Fia,
the Deathbed Companion. Embrace her,
and you'll receive a Baldachin's Blessing.
Now...and it's startling that not many people
realise this - but did you know that
your health is reduced while you
have the blessing in your inventory?
That's right, you lose a few points of
your vigor stat - essentially around 5% health, a
debuff that remains UNTIL you use her Baldachin's
Blessing. There's gotta be some people in the
comments that have kept this thing in their
inventory for hours without a second thought,
I guarantee it. And I don't blame you! The
buff/debuff icons are pretty intense in this
game - as a side note - icons with a square
around them are permanent effects from rings, and
ones with diamonds around them are temporary.
But the biggest question is - is the
Baldachin's Blessing worth it? And..the answer
is..kind of? Sometimes? The Baldachin's
Blessing essentially gives you a type of poise
for about 15 seconds. This is extremely useful
when you're facing a lot of minor enemies,
as you'll completely ignore their small attacks
and only get staggered by their strong attacks.
However, the blessing seems pretty pointless
when facing a single enemy, or any large enemy.
So I'd honestly only really recommend bothering
with this item if you KNOW that extra poise
will serve you well in an encounter to
come - like in a cave with lots of rats,
or demi-humans, or flying projectiles.
But the main reason to go back to Fia every
now and again..is because you'll eventually get
a dialogue option for progressing her questline.
For me, this always appears once I've
moved into the Altus Plateau.
Also, enjoy the cuddles. Or don't. You can
also just warp out of them if you think the
animation is too long. Though things like
this are why you're maidenless, you know.
For number 14, have you ever found yourself
disappointed with the amount of armours that
you can alter? Well, you can actually expand
your options by acquiring the Gold Sewing
Needle in Liurnia, in a chest to the right when
you enter the Church of Vows, located here.
Furthermore, if you progressed Boc's questline
in Limgrave after talking to him here...and
here...then you'll find him again in
Liurnia, at the East Raya Lucaria Gate. Here,
Boc will perform your armour alterations for
you for free, even taking the Gold Sewing
Needle from you, if you should so desire.
Finally..everyone knows about the whetstone knife
at the Gateside Ruins that lets you apply
ashes of war - but did you know that there are
or quality scaling...and is located in Stormveil
castle - or the glintstone whetblade, which adds
magic scaling, located in Raya Lucaria.
Thank you for watching. Special thanks
to Absa who helped me with some
of the research for this video.
Again, check out our Secret Seekers covenant and
merch if you're interested - and i'll see you next
time.